peu
c'est un élan jacky marche à la voile et
marche très très vite
alors jeune performances conçu autour
d'une idée de base traverser
l'atlantique le plus vite possible à la
voile un bonhomme tout seul à bord et
celui ci est très bon et puis à battre
les grands prix valises
c'est valable pour toutes les formules
de bonheur en plus de cela le très
puissant il est très homogène et très
rigide
il a été pour son plan de pont conçu par
un grand spécialiste avec tabarly la
baisse procter à côté des secours le
bateau
j'ai tout fait à paris j'étais étudiant
en lettres et un beau jour j'ai vu
passer une annonce dans un créneau pour
demander un maître de conférences à la
faculté des lettres de sydney sorti la
balle et en australie et surtout à six
mois la voile s'impose
la belle est extraordinaire les
sillonnaient de voilier s'était tout de
suite rappelle je fais mes collègues
pratiquer la voile
ils m'ont fait découvrir ces mondes cbi
et jacques rocher meilleure forme j'ai
navigué comme ça non avec les rebelles
s'ils né puis un jour j'ai voulu aller
au large alors je me suis engagé comme
comme fringe coupe comme cuisinier sur
les relier de cos troisième les bateaux
en haute mer et c'est ainsi découvert le
large
quand je suis fatigué c'est là que je
viens pas me reposer je vais bien massif
est bien calé même quand le bateau dans
ce canton est là et coups de mer
découdre ans ici je suis bien parce que
je parle plus c'est la collision avec un
cargo et c'est ce qui m'a amené à ne
plus dormir que far que par tranches je
prends des petites tranches de sommeil
j'essaie de dormir le moins possible la
nuit je prends les tranches de sommeil
échelonnées sur 24 heures d'une demi
heure d'une heure des fois quand c'est
le luxe je m'offre une heure et demie ou
même deux jours le j'arrive le matin à
prendre une tranche de deux heures de
sommeil sas art as tu bien est ce que je
crois aussi bien sur cc comme tous les
solitaires le risque de passer par
dessus bord et d'avoir personnes pour
vos péchés passés par saison à voir le
bateau qui s'éloigne c'est la hantise de
tous les solitaires ont fait tout ce
cauchemar la un jour l'autre la nuit
le but c'est de gagner parce que cette
course ça fait 80 quand j'aurai quatre
en quatre ans que je me prépare
je mets
j'ai tout sacrifié sur le port du
travail sur le plan financier et même
sur le plan physique
monsieur oblige à avoir froid je me suis
déjà pas dormir des fois j'ai pas mangé
un monde dans certains cas est tous des
fois où j'en ai bavé physiquement
parfois aussi normalement parce que
c'est pas toujours facile de produire un
grand bateau à venir
et son homologue
on va continuer à le maintenir à son
niveau de forme
quant aux concurrents de la course
croisière saint malo pointe à pitre ils
passent leur dernière nuit au calme
avant le grand départ demain vers midi
eric tabarly donnera le coup d'envoi et
40 solitaire se battront alors pendant
près de trois semaines pour franchir en
tête la ligne d'arrivée saint malo la
cité des corsaires nous de façon
spectaculaire avec le grand océan devant
ses murailles la première
transatlantique française lâchera sur la
mer une cinquantaine de navigateurs
solitaires 6500 kilomètres de saint malo
à la guadeloupe avec un premier but
reprendre à l'anglais l'hégémonie qu'il
exerce sur l'organisation des courses au
large et surtout concurrencer la célèbre
transat ou tabarly s'illustra par deux
fois la différence actuellement avec
nouveau règlement c'est qu'on peut
prendre n'importe quel bateau c'est
clair mais je craque sur tout le
parcours est différent c'est la première
fois qu'on part sur ce parcours ce sera
plus intéressant il ya beaucoup plus
d'options après moi sur ce parcours la
transat anglaise a été marquée par
l'empreinte tabarly mais la transat
française partira sans lui enfin presque
car c'est lui qui donnera le départ il
aura en plus la satisfaction de revoir
sur la ligne son vieux pen duick iv le
prestigieux ancêtre du trimaran de
course
rebaptisé manureva par alain colas les
50 solitaire qui partiront pour une
traversée de l'atlantique n'ont pas tous
choisi les mêmes solutions il y aura au
départ une quinzaine de trimarans un
catamaran et toute une flottille de
monocoques des trimarans il y en a de
toutes les formes comme celui ci as de
pique son skipper l'a construit lui-même
sa coque fait vingt mètres de long mais
environ 80 cm de large
d'autres ont choisi des bateaux de
croisière confortable comme jean pierre
barrau ancien skipper du bel espoir
le bateau du père jaouen
et pour prouver qu'un bateau de
croisière équipe est complètement peut
naviguer naviguer vite même par rapport
à débattre très affûté sont destinés à
une course et qui peuvent pas faire
grand chose d'autre ça c'est l'intérêt
du constructeur mais l'intérêt du
skipper l'intérêt du skipper ben ma foi
je suis pas encore une vedette j'ai
encore jamais fait de course donc viser
un sponsoring pour un très grand bateau
pour quelque chose de très spécial c'est
difficile et je ne suis pas je suis plus
un routier de la main moi je fais des
jets des convoyages des choses comme ça
je fais pas tellement de courses alors
c'est plus pour le plaisir personnel
bonjour donc plaisir personnel puis pour
aller aux antilles avec un bateau qui
ferait je resterai antilles avec le
bateau oui mais je vais bien quand même
je vais vite quand même le plaisir de la
course sans doute pour jean pierre
barrau pour d'autres c'est la
compétition et toutes ces contraintes
qui prime pas plus de trois quart
d'heures de sommeil consécutifs pendant
plus de vingt jours une alimentation
réduite au nécessaire
le bateau qu'il faut pousser à chaque
instant au maximum de ses possibilités
c'est cela la course une des formes de
l'aventuré humaine mail aventure tout
court existe-t-elle encore chaque
parcelle d'océan était sillonnée dans
tous les sens cette route des antilles
en particulier laventure il faut
peut-être alors la chercher ailleurs
je pense qu'il reste peut-être pas à
tant au niveau de la compétition je
pense qu'au niveau compétition est un
peu saturé
toutes sortes de nouveautés
c'est finalement il ya le côté aventure
disparaître petit à petit parce qu'on
devient de plus en plus sélectifs
maintenant les compétitions sont très
deviennent professionnels mais par
contre au point de vue navigation et mer
mais il reste des aventures
extraordinaires aviv il ya qu'à voir
damien ce moment au pôle sud
enfin il ya eu l'idée de rousseau
passage du nord-ouest yahia d aventure
formidable encore à faire un verre il
s'en fait tout le temps il ya tout ce
dont on ne parle pas qui font le tour du
monde et lampard tous les jours on en
rencontre aura sans doute en route
cette transatlantique française risque
de réserver bien des surprises
à cette époque de l'année l'océan n'est
pas toujours tranquille
les prototypes construits spécialement
pour cette course risquent de souffrir
en cas de mauvais temps mais le trimaran
qui atteindront des vitesses
phénoménales dans les vents arrières des
alizés ont toutes les chances de
remporter la course
à moins que la grande côte bleue de
michel malinovski deviennent remporté in
extremis le prix de 200 mille francs
offerts aux vainqueurs 48 heures ont
maintenant passé depuis la fantastique
arrivée au sprint de la transatlantique
française et l'enthousiasmé provoqué par
le corps-à-corps birch malinowski s'est
progressivement transformé en inquiétude
ou presque on angoisse pour alain colas
voilà douze jours maintenant qui n'a
plus donné de ses nouvelles et les
breaks et de la marine nationale ont
commencé à ratisser l'atlantique est
le bréguet de la marine nationale basé à
la guadeloupe survolent actuellement
l'atlantique à la recherche des
concurrents qui n'ont pas donné de leurs
nouvelles depuis plusieurs jours parmi
eux alain colas le navigateur français
n'a pas donné signe de vie depuis 14
jours alors dément
j'ai panne de radio peut-être cela
expliquerait sans retard et son silence
accidents corporels
c'est imaginable car depuis l'accident
de 1976 n'a pas récupéré totalement
usage de son pied son frère
jean-françois évoque cette éventualité
lorsqu'on est seul sur un bateau et peut
se passer des tas de choses et et pour
le moment je ne préfère pas l'envisager
il est handicapé alain colas au son pied
j'imagine le jeune dans une épreuve
comme celle ci avec les difficultés
qu'on connaît
oui il faut beaucoup de courage il a il
a un pied qui est pas le même que notre
âme il a besoin d'y faire de faire très
attention car il n'a aucune sensibilité
son pied tout à fait insensible si je
fais le moindre bobo ne le sent pas il
peut pas et il faut le surveiller et ça
peut tout de suite prendre des
proportions importantes m'enfin il a
l'habitude
il vit maintenant avec ce pied je pense
qu'il pourra je peux bien qui peut
parfaitement se débrouiller il l'a
prouvé
puis des nouvelles des autres
concurrents jeunes riguidel déjà victime
d'un abordage avec un ferry boat au
départ a eu la malchance de heurter un
rocher à antigua son bateau est très
alliés mais le skippeur est sain et sauf
messieurs bonsoir jusqu alors nous
avions essayé de ne pas trop montrer
notre inquiétude à propos du sort
d'alain colas qui n'est toujours pas
arrivé à pointe-à-pitre mais cette fois
disons le on a vraiment peur pour lui le
bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale est revenue bredouille de sa
mission
la nuit dernière joël charpentier le
trégastellois qui est arrivé 5e hier et
qui avait une journée de retard sur
colas lors du dernier pointage il ya
deux semaines à confronter son journal
de bord avec celui de michel malinovski
lui aussi avait un peu de retard sur
colas il avait choisi de la même route
et bien une certitude il est arrivé
quelque chose et peut-être quelque chose
de grave
tous les radioamateurs sont d'ailleurs
mobilisés depuis quelques heures pour
essayer de retrouver le navigateur
en tout cas pour essayer de percevoir la
moindre tentative de liaison radio
est ce que vous pourriez sur certaines
fréquences capter les radios des bateaux
sur la route du rhum celle d'alain colas
par exemple dit oui aujourd'hui à titre
exceptionnel nous avons droit d'écouter
les fréquences hautes que celles qui
sont radio amateur et compte tenu des
circonstances les plus exceptionnels
disons on peut effectivement aujourd'hui
et vous avez reçu quel instruction
uniquement des côtés de noter le nom du
bateau les coordonnées géographiques de
ce bateau et de retransmettre toutes ces
informations en station côtière
officiels qui sont chargés de faire mes
achats après le repérage c'est
maintenant la recherche
le bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale qui avait été utilisé pour des
missions de repérage des concurrentes
est il ya de recevoir les profils de
fouiller l'atlantique à la recherche des
solitaires dont on est sans nouvelles
cette première mission de sécurité de
sauvetage a été effectué hier au large
de l'île eau de coco 1 ou 7 et échoué
gouvernail cassé le trimaran vld pendant
deux heures
le bréguet atlantique a survolé les
parents dommages et du voilier jusqu'à
fait qu'un petit canot à moteur
intrigués par le manège de cet avion se
porte au secours deux jeunes riguidel
qui aidèrent pays sains et saufs cette
mission accomplie le bret qui a survolé
pendant toute la journée
la zone dans laquelle sont supposés la
ligue et les voiliers de cette province
aujourd'hui un autre breguet atlantic
partie des docteurs survol lui aussi les
routes de la course
mais malgré les instruments les plus
perfectionnés dans un cerf la marine
nationale
il faut bien reconnaître que sa tâche
n'est pas facile cherchez un voilier
dont on ne venez pas la position depuis
longtemps c'est presque aussi difficile
que de chercher une aiguille dans une
botte de foin et c'est le cas
précisément de bannu et 20
le voilier d'alagoas dont on a perdu la
trace depuis quinze jours
sa famille inquiète est intervenu pour
que des recherches approfondies cette
entreprise force est de reconnaître ce
soir qu'elles n'ont pas abouti ce qui
commence à devenir inquiétant mais les
solitaires qui sont déjà arrivés à
pointe à pitre refuse de croire en la
catastrophe et préfère penser que alain
colas et qui me donne envie d'en re
technique rallye pointe à pitre avec des
moyens de fortune et que dans ces
conditions le retard et peut taper
explique aussi le bateau eu un accident
et forcément rien accident il y a
quelque chose de terrible est ce un mât
qui s'est abattue ce qui arrive
temps arrêté l'émission puisqu'elle est
plus d'antennes rien et peut-être aussi
les accus voyez c'est tout temps paris a
vu pas mal de tempêtes cette époque là
on avait noté un cyclone doit à l'époque
d'ailleurs malinowski se trouvait au
calme dans l'oeil du cyclone nuit et en
plus à côté de la navette est peut-être
sur les bords du cycle aller prenait
davantage de secousses mais il était
habitué à ça n'est ce pas faut pas
oublier qu'il a traversé les
quarantièmes les cinquantièmes
rugissants ou la mère était terrible
parce qu'a fait avoue conserver l'espoir
conserve toujours l espoir à la est un
excellent marin il est résistant malgré
son pied on accuse d'un tas de choses il
est parti en pleine forme confirmé par
le dr bâ revel qui est l'éminent
chirurgien qui a fait la grève de son qe
discours lu par alain colo n'avait pas
quelques appréhensions
absolument pas je n'ai jamais vu aussi
joyeux depuis longtemps il était heureux
de renouer avec son bateau et avec la
mer d'ailleurs comme sa femme insultes
dire d'eux a failli abeilles avaient
déjà huit jours qu'il était temps mr
donc il est parti on va travailler donc
il ya encore des possibilités de le
retrouver
nous espérons qui a selon le terme
employé souvent par son frère qui va
débouler un moment quelconque sur une
côte où vers la guadeloupe ou ailleurs
est ce que la façon dont les recherches
ont été conduites vous en satisfait
écoutez ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils
croyaient devoir faire je ne suis pas
habilité à juger ces gens là les
les gars des avions d atlantic le
bréguet atlantique étaient des gens
consciencieux qui faisaient bien leur
boulot
seulement la mère est immense il
faudrait poursuivre ses recherches et
fait des recherches sur les yeux est
poursuivi et c'est certainement dans
dans ces derniers jours quitterait lui
est au contraire intensifier ou alien
est stoppée ou tout au moins extrêmement
diminué puisque à l'heure actuelle n'y a
qu'un avion qui part de pointe à pitre
et vous savez sur douze heures de vol
quand jean-françois était dans un de ses
avions sur deux heures de vol il y avait
à peu près trois heures de recherche
d'exploration
le reste c'est l'aller et le retour le
rayon d'action été atteint c'est fini sk
cole avait déjà imaginé pouvoir se
trouvait dans une situation très
difficile car il en a souvent en parlait
que pouvait s'y trouver il s'est trouvé
d'ailleurs dans les situations
nous avons été pendant le tour du monde
par le cap horn trois semaines sans
avoir aucune nouvelle
vraiment nous n'étions pas inquiet on
savait qu avant sa radio avait flanché
où tous sont elles tout mis sur le
compte de la radio
d'ailleurs c'est exact parce que
dimanche je vais déjà dit enfin vous
voulez que nous allions faire une visite
sortir quoi je suis innocent pas alain
20 pelé une demi heure après ils nous
appelaient se rétablir le contact la
radio fonctionne je cherchais à bord
voilà royer trois semaines à point et là
il ya plus de radio du tout c'est ça qui
nous inquiète
[Musique]